[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein es ist der
tag vor dem osterfest für die orthodoxen
christen in der ukraine und in russland
es ist für sie das höchste fest des
jahres ostern in zeiten des krieges ist
die sonne an einem regentag sagt eine
ukrainerin auf der flucht vor den bomben
doch hoffnungen auf eine österliche
waffenruhe sind vergebens die botschaft
von tod und auferstehung in zeiten des
krieges auch heute wieder russische
attacken treffen unter anderem die
ukrainische hafenstadt odessa während
die russische seite nur den beschuss
eines munitionslagers auf einem
militärflughafen nahe der stadt erwähnt
zeigen bilder anderes von raketen
getroffen ein hochhaus in odessa
mindestens acht menschen sollen nach
ukrainischen angaben gestorben sein
darunter auch ein drei monate altes baby
18 menschen seien verletzt worden aus
der ukraine berichtet dominik
löschmeister
es gibt keine osternacht die sie heute
feiern können in kiew der gottesdienst
in sankt nikolaus ist nachmittags am
abend gilt eine sperrstunde im land und
krieg seiner gemeinde halt geben wichtig
für vater wenig
unser feind ist unmenschlich wir beten
zu gott dass er uns geschützt und diese
feiertage friedlich und ruhig gefeiert
werden können
für die gläubigen zu hause übertragen
sie die messe im internet vor der kirche
empfangen sie den österlichen segen
normalerweise lassen wir samstags den
osterkuchen segnen und selbst jetzt
während der kriegszeit haben wir uns
dazu entschieden wir wollen diesen
feiertag mit unseren freunden feiern
vielerorts in der ukraine wird es keine
ostermesse geben die kirchen zerstört
wie hier in lucka schiff nördlich von
kiel die russen lagerten munition in dem
gotteshaus die ukrainischen streitkräfte
beschossen es um sie zu vertreiben
ostern ohne kirche
welcher gottesdienst die kirchen um uns
herum wurden zerstört dörfer wurden
bombardiert
wir können jetzt nirgendwo hin wir
hatten so eine schöne kirche es ist eine
schande
pasqua so heißt der traditionelle
osterkuchen in der ukraine
man isst ihn zusammen mit der familie
die soldaten und soldatinnen in dieser
stellung vor kiew können ostern nicht
mit ihren liebsten feiern
ich besuche normalerweise meine mutter
aber sie ist in der jetzt besetzten
region hessen dieser feiertag ist
normalerweise wichtig für mich aber
meine familie ist jetzt auch hier
zumindest auf den osterkuchen sollen sie
nicht verzichten die waffen werden nicht
schweigen auch um ein feiertag
doch meine glas meister ist für uns in
kiew dominik guten abend beginnen wir
mit der orthodoxen osternacht jetzt da
war ja in kiew in den letzten tagen
wieder so etwas wie vorsichtige rückkehr
ins leben zu spüren wie sieht das heute
aus
ja man sieht schon menschen tagsüber auf
der straße auch heute an diesem
orthodoxen ostersamstag es gibt gibt
cafés die offen haben restaurants
ich habe heute sogar einen
blumenverkäufer am straßenrand gesehen
aber man muss schon sagen es ist hier
schon noch eine angst zu spüren bei den
menschen die angst dass dieser krieg
auch nach kiew wieder stärker
zurückkommt und dann gucken wir dominik
auf die mögliche strategie russlands da
sorgt jetzt ein hochrangiger russischer
militärkommandeur für aufsehen nach
dessen worten der gesamte süden der
ukraine im visier sei und auch die
angrenzende republik moldau sich
durchaus sorgen machen muss wir schauen
uns die region vielleicht mal auf einer
karte an und können dann hier sehen
straff irrt die mehrheitlich von
russland gehaltenen gebiete orange
eingefärbt die aktuellen umkämpften
regionen gucken wie jetzt aber
vielleicht mal richtung süden und westen
dominik was könnte diese strategie für
diese gebiete dort bedeuten
ja also die sorge ist groß dass es nicht
nur um den don was geht sondern darum
den süden der ukraine so die hafenstadt
odessa und transnistrien das ist eine
abtrünnige republik der republik moldau
und transnistrien wird von den russen
kontrollierter sind auch russische
truppen und der republik moldau gibt es
natürlich jetzt große sorge dass diese
diese diese diese diese linie jetzt
gezogen wird transnistrien quasi über
die süd ukraine bis in den donnerstag
kein nato mitglied im gegensatz zum
beispiel zu polen und dem baltikum das
ist natürlich bisher nur ein szenario
aber präsident zuletzt gewarnt die
europäer davor dass ja die ukraine nicht
das letzte ziel der russischen invasoren
sein könnte neue sorgen am orthodoxen
osterfest dominic west meister live in
kiew herzlichen dank dominik der krieg
in der ukraine und die deutsche haltung
dazu ist längst streitthema in der
innenpolitik bei uns er bestimmt auch
einen fdp parteitag der besonderen art
mit einem vorsitzenden der wegen corona
infektion nur mit technischen problemen
von weit weg dabei sein kann und mit
einer partei die ihren kurs sucht
zwischen koalitionsfrieden und kritik am
kanzler christian von rechenberg
berichtet schön dich wiederzusehen nach
zwei jahren ein parteitag in präsenz die
delegierten in berlin beinahe in
partylaune sie währte nur kurz weil ich
der debatte um waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine und den weg dorthin sie geht
voran marie agnes strack zimmermann ist
omnipräsent ist am nie gesucht und setzt
den ton das gebot der stunde heißt den
ukrainern wie in unserem antrag
gefordert auch schwere waffen zu liefern
die ukraine muss sich zur wehr setzen
können
alles gesagt der parteitag feiert seine
identifikationsfigur eigentlich ihm
zugeschrieben doch parteichef lindner
ist in corona quarantäne aus den usa nur
zugeschaltet technisch nicht ganz
fehlerfrei gesundheitlich angeschlagen
mahnt er zu enger abstimmung mit den
nato partnern wir müssen alles was in
unserer macht steht tun um der ukraine
zum sieg zu verhelfen
aber die verantwortungs ethische grenze
ist die gefährdung unserer eigenen
sicherheit
bloß nicht kriegspartei werden trotzdem
entschlossen handeln der bundesvorstand
hat dazu einen antrag vorgelegt 11
punkte vielen geht er nicht weit genug
die ukraine braucht auf jeden fall nur
unterstützung durch waffen ich
persönlich gehöre auch zu den vertretern
der these dass wir auch aus deutschland
etwas andere schwere waffen ja brauchen
wir auch aber wir müssen immer abwägen
wie wir uns in deutschland positionieren
und ich denke der ringtausch zum
beispiel das ist eine möglichkeit mit
der wir gute arbeiten könnten auch er
ergreift das wort wie jean dieser heute
zum generalsekretär gewählt der
gebürtige iraner hat diktatur und krieg
erlebt zieht den vergleich zum minsk und
moskau jede form der wirtschaftlichen
zusammenarbeit mit diesen regimen ist
eine schande sie muss schnellstmöglich
beendet werden der parteitag beschließt
am abend genau das und er sendet ein
entscheidendes jahr für schwere waffen
wie sie in die ukraine kommen und von
bleibt offen hauptsache sagt strack
zimmermann
das ist offiziell schwarz auf weiß
ja und dann guckt die fdp natürlich
gespannt darauf wie ihr
koalitionspartner im
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland dasteht
dort will cdu ministerpräsident hendrik
wüst seine erste wahl als regierungschef
gewinnen was immer in nrw passiert es
schlägt auf die stimmung bundesweit
alter wahlkampfspruch der sich immer
wieder bewahrheitet und auch jetzt
gelten dürfte denn erfolg oder
misserfolg auch des neuen cdu
bundesvorsitzenden zeigt sich in dessen
heimat nordrhein-westfalen am 15 mai ist
dort war heute beginnt die heiße phase
im wahlkampf
ralph goldmann hat mehr
es ist eine große inszenierung heute
mittag in düsseldorf und es ist
wahlkampf premiere für ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst vor sechs monaten hatte er
das amt von armin laschet übernommen
jetzt geht er erst einmal auf attacke in
richtung bundeskanzler olaf scholz der
blockiere die lieferung schwerer waffen
für die ukraine die deutsche
bundesregierung hat immer lange gezögert
und gezaudert
noch nie war deutschland so teilnahmslos
und isoliert in europa wie heute der
zauber kurs des kanzlers und der spd ist
ein schlimmer gewesen aus berlin ist
friedrich merz nach düsseldorf gekommen
begrüßt demonstrativ eine delegation aus
der ukraine
von olaf scholz erwartet der nächste
woche im bundestag eine
regierungserklärung und eine aussprache
sagt er falls nicht werde die union
einen eigenen antrag stellen es gibt ja
im deutschen bundestag eine mehrheit für
waffenlieferungen auch für schwere
waffen an die ukraine
cdu/csu fdp und grüne sind dafür die spd
zögert ich biete der spd auch
ausdrücklich an dass wir einen
gemeinsamen antrag in den deutschen
bundestag einbringen so sticht
bundespolitik derzeit in nrw deutlich
landespolitik wüst herausforderer thomas
kutschaty von der spd wirbt der waren an
duisburger haustüren um wählerstimmen
ihm kann die diskussion um den
bundeskanzler nicht recht sein
vielleicht sogar schaden die cdu hat
ganz offensichtlich ein wahlkampf
problem in nordrhein-westfalen sonst
würde sie solche aggressiven töne
überhaupt nicht benutzen gibt überhaupt
keinen anlass daran zu zweifeln dass
olaf scholz und die bundesregierung
genau die richtigen schritte unternehmen
werden waffen in die ukraine geliefert
aber mit bedacht in den jüngsten
umfragen liegt die spd inzwischen sogar
knapp vor der cdu vielleicht auch wegen
der sogenannten mallorca affäre um
umweltministerin ursula heinen esser von
der cdu die musste zurücktreten weil sie
nach der flutkatastrophe den geburtstag
ihres mannes auf mallorca gefeiert hatte
gestern dann traf die spd die so
genannte spionageaffäre ein mitarbeiter
der fraktion hatte der 16 jährigen
tochter der ex umweltministerin eine
kontaktanfrage bei instagram gestellt
möglicherweise um dort belastendes
material zu finden
für die venen wird all das aber kaum
eine rolle spielen glaubt der
parteienforscher karl-rudolf korte
das rennen sei völlig offen man kann
sogar soweit gehen dass vielleicht auch
der zweite am wahlabend am ende noch
sieger werden kann nicht der
mehrheitsführer wird automatisch
ministerpräsident sondern der beste
sondiere denn einer dieser beiden wird
am ende vielleicht die grünen und die
fdp brauchen um das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland regieren zu können ampel oder
jamaika das sind derzeit die
wahrscheinlichsten koalitionen in nrw
so und jetzt weitere wichtige
nachrichten an diesem samstag und die
hat hanna die eu hat sich auf ein neues
digital gesetz geeinigt dass online
nutzer besser schützen soll was offline
illegal ist soll künftig auch online
verboten sein dazu gehören zum beispiel
hass und hetze gewaltaufrufe und
desinformationen aber auch der verkauf
gefälschter produkte unternehmen wie
google meter oder amazon müssen illegale
inhalte künftig zeitnah löschen sobald
sie ihnen gemeldet werden plattformen
drohen hohe geldstrafen wenn sie die
neuen bestimmungen systematisch
missachten das europaparlament und die
eu staaten müssen dem gesetz noch
zustimmen
in kraft tritt es frühestens 2023
im vergangenen jahr hatten die grünen in
baden württemberg einen parteiausschluss
gegen den tübinger oberbürgermeister
boris palmer beschlossen nun hat das
landesschiedsgericht einen vergleich
vorgeschlagen bis ende 2023 soll palmer
seine mitgliedschaft ruhen lassen
außerdem soll in gesprächen geklärt
werden wie der politiker in zukunft
kontroverse meinungen äußern kann ohne
gegen die ordnung der partei zu
verstoßen grund für das
ausschlussverfahren sind umstrittene
äußerungen des politikers
etwa 2000 menschen haben im moment
nordrhein-westfälischen lutzerath am
rande des tagebaus garzweiler gegen den
abbau von braunkohle demonstriert zudem
wollen sie verhindern dass der bereits
verlassenen ort für die
braunkohleförderung abgebaggert wird zu
der kundgebung hatten unter anderem der
umweltverband
un de vries und friday future aufgerufen
bei einer heftigen explosion in einer
illegalen ölraffinerie im südosten
nigerias sind dutzende menschen ums
leben gekommen
zur genauen zahl der toten gibt es
unterschiedliche angaben medienberichten
unter berufung auf behördenvertreter von
mindestens 50 toten
die genaue ursache des unglücks ist noch
nicht bekannt
in venedig hat die biennale heute ihre
pforten für kunstbegeisterte aus aller
welt geöffnet und gleich am ersten tag
wurden die wichtigsten preise des
festivals vergeben zwei der goldenen
löwen gingen an die schwarzen
künstlerinnen sonja boys und simon lee
für ihr lebenswerk wurde die
düsseldorfer künstlerin katharina
fritsch geehrt die biennale gilt als
eines der wichtigsten foren für
gegenwartskunst bis ende november werden
1500 arbeiten präsentiert außerdem sind
80 länder mit eigenen pavillons teil der
biennale
und noch die sportmeldungen des tages
der fc bayern münchen hat es wieder
einmal geschafft die mannschaft von
trainer julian nagelsmann ist meister
der fußball bundesliga mit einem 3 1
gegen erzrivale dortmund besiegelten die
münchner den vorzeitigen titelgewinn
es ist der zehnte meistertitel in folge
und insgesamt der 32 jetzt die
lottozahlen lauten 13
29 32 34 38 47 und die superzahl 6 alle
angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
geht noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten
morgen bleibt es im norden bei einem mix
aus sonne und wolken trocken im süden
überwiegen die wolken dazu gibt es
südlich der donau gewittrige schauer
sonst regnet es auch länger im norden
weht ein lebhafter nordost wind die
temperatur steigt auf werte von 8 bis 18
grad am montag regnet es im westen und
süden am dienstag im süden am mittwoch
überwiegt dann wieder der sonnenschein
und es wird mit 12 bis 18 grad etwas
wärmer
sowieso morgen wieder für sie da und
zwar sehr gerne und gucken dann auf eine
entscheidende wahl für europa wenn klar
wird wer künftig in frankreich regiert
bis dahin wünschen wir ihnen erst mal
einen schönen abend und die nächsten
nachrichten gibt's hier gegen 0.30 heute
express
[Musik]